we're about to embark upon the trip like  that why did you do that I don't think  we ever gonna get out of this town I'm  telling you seeing Maria today that was  a positive moment Maria oh my god  if you're ever in Manhattan I'll show  you around great yes meeting you Craig  look at her lives now spinning our  wheels job after job for me thanks  [Music]  I'm gonna get fired again oh it's  finally time for that big adventure  brother  I'll talk your road trip to the promised  land yeah Wow  we're not taking my sister's car man he  will kill your sisters in jail every  single one of you we got four whole days  we can keep back relax and breathe in  America it's fun to turn it around or  hold it for you is a little nervous  we're the only black guys in here  [Applause]  missing these dudes right here they  stole my car you know what sometimes you  just got it  it was open  [Music]  with the gorilla  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you